devant tant de malheur est-ce que des
fois vous avez pas envie de vous
révolter contre Dieu
puis je vis en milieu musulman ça aide
aussi parce que ils sont très
inch'Allah
notre invité du samedi 20h ce soir
sereine pour son livre j'ai choisi
d'être médecin chez les Touaregs publié
chez plomb alors ma sœur bonsoir je suis
très heureux de vous recevoir ce soir
car ces derniers temps lorsque l'on
parle de l'Église catholique c'est
souvent à propos d'interdiction du
préservatif de prêtres pédophiles mais
il y a aussi des religieuses qui sauvent
des milliers de gens en Afrique et c'est
justement votre cas big up
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voulais vous dire que j'ai détesté
votre livre parce que j'ai eu en le
lisant l'impression d'être un gros nul
égoïste
[Musique]
Marie rebonsoir je pourrais dire
Anne-Marie biscuit rebonsoir puisque
c'est le surnom qu'on vous donne dans le
désert du Mali vous avez distribué des
tonnes de biscuits donnés par la Croix
Rouge
alors ma sœur l'avocation vous est venu
à quel âge je voulais être diacré
médecin quand j'étais enfant je ne sais
pas où j'avais pris ça mais diacre c'est
pas bon pour les femmes et médecins je
ne voyais pas à quoi ça correspondait
dans mon idée j'ai trouvé ça en Afrique
alors parallèlement à votre novicia vous
faites des études assez poussées jusqu'à
la maîtrise de physique
mais l'idée d'aller en Afrique vous
taraude et c'est vrai qu'en Afrique un
physicien d'hôpital c'est pas très utile
et vous décidez de faire des études de
médecine et vous commencez la médecine à
45 ans alors au départ en fait des
stages en Afrique en alternance avec
votre externat et votre internat
jusqu'au jour où vous décidez d'aller
vous installer à Gossip grossiste au
Mali c'est loin de Bamako 1050 km donc
il y a 1050 km de 4x4 avant d'arriver
là-bas
et quand on arrive c'est comment le jour
où je suis arrivé la première fois
c'était marcher au chameau c'est
magnifique alors il y a quelqu'un qui
est très important là-bas pour vous
c'est votre adjoint ado
c'est grâce à sa famille que vous êtes
intégré là-bas et il a pensé quand je
suis arrivée que c'était Dieu qui m'a
envoyé le chercher
alors il dit un truc formidable sur vous
il dit rien de ce qu'elle fait n'est
pour elle
c'est joli
c'est sans doute vrai je pense
ça se passe comment pour vous là-bas
vous levez à quelle heure le matin vers
6h mais je demande qu'on ne me dérange
pas avant 7h30 pour avoir le temps de
prier de prendre mon temps pour faire
surface et prendre mon petit déjeuner et
à partir de 7h30 alors là ça fera ça
frappe vous avez une chaîne du désert
avec vous
comme la mère de Sarkozy
[Musique]
je ne connais pas à cause de ça j'espère
ma sœur je connais pas la mère de
Sarkozy et après vous travaillez toute
la journée jusqu'à quelle heure ça
dépend vraiment le soir s'il y a des
urgences il y a pas beaucoup d'heures
le mardi vous occupez des femmes
vous êtes la seule à faire de la
gynécologie là-bas avec la femme de ZADO
vous faites 300 accouchements par an on
fait oui entre nous à peu près
1000 femmes enceintes vous refusez de
faire des avortements
on va bien sûr ce n'est pas ni dans mes
idées ni dans celle de ados ni dans
celle de dijatoul la femme de ZADO en
revanche contrairement au Vatican vous
êtes d'accord pour la pilule et pour le
préservatif c'est à dire que nous avons
des petites femmes qui se marie très
jeunes que l'on marie très jeune et 13
14 ans qui ne peuvent pas accoucher et
qui doivent être césarisés après les
césariennes elles reviennent avec un
papier de l'hôpital qu'il ne faut pas
qu'elles aient d'enfants pendant deux
ans bon si ces petites femmes retournent
chez leur mari mais qu'elle dise à leur
mari qu'elles ne peuvent pas avoir
d'enfants elles vont être jetées elles
vont être divorcés donc pour éviter ça
ces médicaments si vous voulez je leur
demande de prendre la pilule ou bien on
leur fait des piqûres prévues pour ça le
gros problème évidemment pour les femmes
ce sont les mers célibataires parce que
souvent les gamines sont violées et
ensuite
sont enceinte elles sont rejetées et
c'est pour ça qu'on les marie très jeune
il y en a qui sont mariés à 11 12 ans
pour éviter qu'elle soit enceinte et
rejetée après c'est ça il y a une
coutume qui est assez terrible c'est à
dire que pour les rendre désirable
on les attache et on les gave de lait
avec un entonnoir ce qui fait certaines
fois il y en a qui meurent de cette
pratique mais depuis que je suis là j'ai
quand même beaucoup fait prendre
conscience au grand-mère et aux mamans
que c'était pas bon pour la santé que
c'était pas bon pour l'enfant
dans le sud du Mali j'ai entendu dire
qu'il y avait 95 à 96% des filles qui
sont excisées dans ma région il y avait
autrefois les sons rails les sédentaires
pratiquaient l'excision sur des grandes
filles et il y a eu beaucoup d'accidents
et ils ont complètement arrêté alors il
y a plus que quelques personnes du Sud
qui sont chez nous
ou bien les gens du des pêcheurs mais
les Touaregs ne pratiquent pas
l'excision jamais et voilées
non chez nous ce ne sont pas voilés il y
a juste si il y a une petite
une petite quantité d'intégrisme mais
c'est des intégristes
qui ne sont pas
farouches mais elles sont voilées mais
elles viennent beaucoup se faire soigner
par nous parce qu'elle voit qu'on les
respecte et pendant les consultations
elles se dévoile je l'exige le mardi
donc c'est les femmes Le jeudi vous
occupez des tuberculeux
le samedi décidez un le sida il
l'attrape quand ils vont travailler à
Abidjan par exemple
ce qui est très bizarre c'est qu'en fait
le SIDA est une maladie beaucoup moins
disons étonnante pour eux
que le choléra ou l'épilepsie qui sont
considérés en fait par par les habitants
de Gossi comme des maladies un peu
diaboliques surtout l'épilepsie mais on
essaye de leur faire comprendre que en
leur donnant des médicaments ça va
s'arranger et que c'est une maladie
comme les autres mais c'est difficile
alors les blancs là-bas sont toujours
perçus comme des colons comme celui qui
qui dirige qui apporte l'argent c'est à
dire que nous avons des
nous avons la télévision et la
télévision il y a certains films qui
passent tous les jours et alors bon
c'est comme les Dallas sont des choses
comme ça donc pour eux ils pensent que
tous les Blancs ont la même chose ont
des châteaux ou des grands appartements
des beaucoup d'argent tout le monde à la
télé tout le monde est riche donc quand
ils voient des blancs il leur demande un
petit peu de les aider alors votre
hôpital coûte 150000 euros par an
comment vous financez ça ma sœur
alors je vais me dire c'est Dieu
par la main de
certaines personnes par la main d'ONG
qui se donnent beaucoup
j'ai des j'ai plusieurs ONG qui m'aident
et les personnes
s'investissent beaucoup dans la
recherche de fonds et dans l'aide que
l'on m'apporte ça va financièrement je
viens tous les ans pour faire la quête
pour dire merci à ceux qui m'apportent
quand vous arrivez en France là vous
pensez quoi de notre monde quel regard
vous portez sur la société française
actuellement
dans les grandes surfaces de pour faire
des courses quoi ça vraiment j'ai du mal
pourquoi
je ne sais pas je vois trop je vois trop
de nourriture je vois parce que chez
nous un magasin il y a quoi du Mille du
riz du sardines à l'huile c'est tout
c'est abondance ça vous ça vous pèse
finalement
40% de ce qu'on produit en nourriture
parce que sinon ça se chiffre là on
jette 40 % de ce qu'on fabrique
mais je veux pas juger vous avez votre
avis quand même oui je supporte pas très
très bien quoi je préfère je préfère
là-bas comment elle a dit là-bas au fond
elle est dure elle est douce
je parle pas pour vous je parle pour les
gens pour les gens
et là actuellement les les trois régions
de Gao Kidal et Tombouctou sont
déclarés sinistrés parce que l'herbe n'a
pas poussé assez haut l'année dernière
pendant la saison des pluies et l'herbe
qui aurait dû servir jusque jusqu'au
mois d'avril et déjà fini depuis un mois
donc
il y a beaucoup les gens commencent à
descendre vers le sud c'est vraiment
très dur devant tant de misère devant
tant de malheur est-ce que des fois vous
avez pas envie de vous révolter contre
Dieu
puis je vis en milieu musulman ça aide
aussi parce que ils sont très
inch'Allah quand j'ai des soucis
d'argent et ça arrive ZADO me dit mais
pourquoi vous inquiétez vous Dieu va
nous envoyer quelque chose et c'est vrai
ça se fait finalement vous êtes une
bonne sœur catholique qui a découvert
l'islam et qui le respectent beaucoup
beaucoup
d'Islam pensez que Dieu a besoin
d'interprète comme vous pour transmettre
son message d'amour je pense
vous êtes très calme c'est incroyable
parce que on se souvient de sœur
Emmanuel qui était très agité j'ai
appris ça avec les Touaregs
ils sont pacifiques ils sont chez les
j'aime bien je suis je suis très à
l'aise chez eux
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu